*Clap, clap, clap…
Je sais, il n’est pas 20 heures.
Je prends un peu d’avance.
Mais pourquoi applaudit-on ?
Je vous rejoins dans le jardin.
Nous applaudissons pour manifester
notre admiration, notre enthousiasme, pour encourager.
Ça, d’accord !
Mais pourquoi le fait-on en utilisant les paumes
de nos mains que nous frappons l’une contre l’autre ?
*Clap, clap, clap…
Selon certaines sources, nos ancêtres du paléolithique devaient déjà s’enlacer et se taper le dos.
Les applaudissements seraient en quelque sorte
la reproduction de ce geste à distance.
Au fil du temps, la fonction aussi a évolué.
Les romains ont été les premiers à utiliser les applaudissements comme baromètre politique.
Un sondage avant l’heure.
Usage qui se poursuit d’ailleurs dans l’hémicycle
Selon certains, les applaudissements
créent aussi du lien entre les individus
Un peu comme une « capsule de déconfiné ».
Autre fonction :
Au VIIe siècle, l’empereur romain d’Orient, Héraclius
– à l’époque l’Empire romain touche vraiment à sa fin -
engage des figurants qui se mêlent
à son armée juste pour applaudir,
pour impressionner son ennemi
et lui montrer sa supériorité.
Bon, ça n’a pas très bien marché.
C’est beaucoup plus efficace chez certains animaux.
Dans une publication récente
un chercheur anglais suggère
que les phoques gris battent des membres antérieurs
*Clap, clap, clap…
pour montrer leur supériorité physique
Genre, poussez-vous, c’est moi le plus fort.
C’est peut être aussi le sens de nos applaudissements,
chaque soir depuis la mi-mars.
Nous applaudissons pour dire « Merci ! »
mais aussi parce nous voulons montrer
que nous pouvons être les plus forts
et que nous avons très envie
de lui mettre une bonne claque à ce satané virus.
Si vous avez aimé cette capsule
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
Vous pouvez également voir ou revoir celles des jours précédents en cliquant sur le côté gauche .
J'en publie une nouvelle chaque jour.
Alors pour être sûr de n'en louper aucune
abonnez vous et activez la petite cloche.
A demain et surtout n'oubliez pas : nous sommes toujours confiné mais on reste en lien.